got room for one mo  they call him the hanger  when the handbill says dead allowed the  rest of us just shoot you in the back  from up on top of perch somewhere and  bring you in dead over saddle but when  John Ruth the hangman catches you you  hey this here is Daisy domercant  she's wanted dead or alive for murder  and that Sun comes out I'm taking this  woman to hang there anybody here  committed to stopping me from doing that  well well well looks like Minnie's  haberdashery is about to get cozy for  the next few days yes it does  one of them fellas  it's not what he says he is  move a little strange you're gonna get a  book not a warning not a question a book  now we're talking